my name is Eric person and I am a
graduate student in the quantum
photonics group at MIT and my research
in particular deals with quantum
computing so quantum computing is a new
type of computing that harnesses the
principles of quantum mechanics to do
computations in a fundamentally
different way and in particular this
allows for more powerful calculations of
certain types of problems ranging from
things like factoring large prime
numbers to calculating interactions for
biochemistry and so quantum computing
has been around for some number of years
now and we're starting to get to the
point where we actually have systems of
multiple quantum bits or qubits and
we're starting to try to put them into
large numbers of systems on chip in
particular and quantum computing is
actually experiencing a lot of the same
problems that classical computing
experienced namely that when you have
lots of systems all on one chip very
close together you start to have
problems with crosstalk and problems in
trying to address individual qubits at
the same time and so my work in
particular is trying to look at how we
can develop new techniques for
individually addressing systems of
qubits and particularly the system that
we look at is a nitrogen vacancy Center
in diamond so essentially this is a
defect a single atom defect inside of a
crystal lattice and so that helps us get
pretty far so we have single atom qubits
which is pretty small and pretty compact
but it turns out that actually to talk
these qubits you need to use lasers and
optical addressing and for those who are
familiar objects you may know that
there's something called diffraction
limit which means that the smallest you
can make a laser spot is roughly half
the wavelength and so that sort of
places a fundamental limit you would
think on how narrowly you can address
these qubits and how tightly you can
pack them so what we were able to
develop actually through part of my
Master's work was a technique for using
small differences between these qubits
and slight differences in their
translation frequencies as a result of
their environment to individually
address qubits with very very high
precision and high fidelity and so we
showed that we could have a Samba love
multiple different qubits these little
item atom like defects and diamond and
address a single one at a time without
perturbing the state of the other so we
think this is a really a path forward
towards having really scalable systems
with ten with very densely packed
information on a single chip for quantum
computing